what do you feel is the biggest threat
to our national security today and would
you grit how would you grade the Obama
administration's anti-terrorism
performance I think they've done a great
job on the anti-terrorism so a oh yeah a
plus oh wait um but that doesn't mean
there's no more threat that doesn't mean
there's no more threat you know people
say he shouldn't take credit for what
he's done but I'll tell you if something
blows up they're gonna blame him
so he should take credit for what he's
done because he will also be blamed if
it doesn't work mm-hmm okay Jay madera
says why don't we go back to Reagan time
is when the wealthy paid a lot more in
taxes well okay towns where that Reagan
had a top marginal tax rate of 28% we're
at 35 if and how many times did rig up
to 45 he signed too many tax increases
and the good news is we've learned from
82 which was the significant one when
the Democrats offered him three dollars
of spending cuts for every dollar of tax
increase the tax increase is real we're
still paying it and none of the spending
cuts
none of the spending cuts actually
happened they doubled spending rather
than $2 of spending cuts for every
dollar of tax increase and Bill the real
problem is that the very very wealthiest
people in America now have these devices
where they don't pay any taxes remember
the McCourt's who owned the dodgers
didn't pay any taxes state or federal
for seven years I believe if you are
very very wealthy now Wall Street has
come up with products that will allow
you to live tax-free if you're a
billionaire so you should check into
that I am first you need a billion
dollars that's right yeah okay Eva this
is for you the african-american
community tends to be more conservative
on the gay issue what do you think the
Latino response will be to Obama coming
out for gay marriage you know what now
did the minorities hate on the gays no
we don't get it first of all to
generalize about the Latino view is
really irresponsible because we're a
faction group but it's
if cuz the Bible it well because we're
Catholic a lot of us are Catholic is a
huge majority of Catholic but what's
interesting the study just came out that
said Latinos don't take that issue to
the polls that's like four hundred
actually most people don't take that
issue to the right it's not it's not a
people time to vote on kitchen table
issues fiscal issues national but it's
not social issue ask newest has even
proved in the Bush administration
campaign Latinos are not a conservative
enough for it and also if you look at
the demographic of Latinos where the
youngest ethnicity in the United States
and we're only getting younger and being
young is indicative of being more
accepting more accepting and tolerant of
alternate lifestyles if it wasn't for
religion it wouldn't be an issue at all
right graeme really does come from a
religion it really it mean it's it's you
know in North Carolina was to the black
churches I don't haven't seen an
analysis of other states but that that's
also where you'd want to do your voter
turnout so there's there's a little bit
of a conflict there that Obama is going
to run into what does the panel think of
JP Morgan losing two billion dollars
doing the same risk risking invest risky
investing that caused the 2008 crash I
love that question the brave okay go
ahead when george w bush's
administration bailed out Wall Street
and started the bailout of Detroit when
they bailed out Wall Street nothing
changed nobody lost money on their bets
the executives still get paid the same
way we still don't have glass-steagall
nothing has changed except we've given
them a lot of our tax dollars when the
Obama administration bailed out the auto
industry everybody took a haircut the
shareholders got wiped out the CEO and
the janitor both took care of the seat
yes they did disproportionately the
older bondholders didn't know those were
health care claims that no they didn't
and the and but everybody took a haircut
and the executives who had deferred
compensation lost half that money
everybody took a loss that's the
difference about how the truth
ministration Street I think the real
thing here with JP Morgan is you know
the Republicans in the House said we
don't need more regulation you know
dodd-frank wasn't necessary this is
proof dodd-frank was necessary they're
still doing all the stuff they were
doing thank God Frank as the law of the
land and this happen how did dodd-frank
fix it because it hasn't been
implemented is not an
that's what has an implement right we've
been regulated the dog brains does not
address fiscal to cut it or credit
default swaps adequately it doesn't it
why doesn't it why doesn't it yes
because the Republicans in the house
wouldn't allow them to do that in the
bill right rod Frank majority in the
house no Republicans had any ability to
have aliens let the bankers who produce
forty percent of the profits in this
country now have enormous influence in
Washington we have been regulating
banking since Hammurabi okay and we knew
how to regulate banking up and tell we
decided starting in 1980 with a series
of acts to stop regulating bankers you
got a regulate banking it is the crucial
central industry you have to regulate a
lot of things we can get rid of
regulation not finance cuz it real
unlimited damage except up except
evidently Fannie and Freddie right who
were forced by and pro and pushed into
buying when they weren't buying toxic
mortgages and they were criticized by
Wall Street Wall Street said they're not
buying these things they're going to
lose market share so they started buying
them and you look at the financial
crisis industry Commission report
inquiry report and it shows they acted
much better than anybody on Wall Street
is there any amount of income inequality
that is bad any amount
well the question is why you have it I
mean if you have income inequality
because the government's got programs
that keep poor people poor him and the
davis-bacon Act keep was originally
there has to keep laughs ricchan
Americans our name is Jay connect well
you know know more about Hammurabi
davis-bacon is in law now robber Abhi's
passed away but that's a law that was
deliberately set up for reasons of
protecting organized labor against black
workers and it makes what year was this
Lopez late 1920s yeah oh they xx it's
still law the late so long I required a
minimum wage owning for it and grubbers
right there were some racist aspects to
it but it was all Tom sure they set it
on the floor the of the Senate in the
house when they passed but it but its
function is also going to take
blue-collar workers like my brother
who's a ditch digger and see to it that
they got a living wage which most
Americans don't have done and by the way
the problem with inequality people
should be paid according to the merits
of how well they work and their success
but what we're doing in this
country is taking massive amounts of tax
dollars and quietly funneling them up to
the richest people in America that's the
real problem with inequality it's a
government policy creating people who
didn't earn the money any suspect so how
was the ditch digging industry going
yeah and by the time your my brother's
age he's sixty you're you're busted up
and you can't work anymore nobody will
hire you they want young people right
but Americans aren't taking those jobs
well meeting the Mexicans oh go ahead
well I went and talked to one of the
guys responsible for defending the
davis-bacon act and he was saying please
help us raise taxes to do more of this
stuff than I said instead of raising
taxes how about getting rid of your let
davis-bacon which keeps the cost up
twenty five to thirty three percent his
response was you want all our highways
built by Hispanics so the good news is
that this disgusting racist law is still
a disgusting racist law they just have a
different target that's your government
at work but if we of all the problems we
have in America it's a major problem and
we could fix it why I would think you'd
be out there going yes let's get rid of
something like that I maybe I am okay
good since I've never heard that farm
subsidies davis-bacon so far maybe I
could it believes me I'm not gonna be on
my breakfast table tomorrow tomorrow
morning bacon no davis-bacon nothing but
but of all the things you know is this
really the top priority is this if you
seem so worked up about Davis big that's
a major injustice and it's wrong and and
if you wonder why your roads weren't in
the very well-built minimum middle class
but I'm sorry higher wages lead to worse
roads that's a difficult at stretch but
no with what davis-bacon does is it
raises the cost of all building of roads
as well and all building of bridges and
less workers are more efficient as
they're paid for but and then in the big
picture Grover like I just read this
week that corporate profits are fact
finally back to their pre recession
levels fifteen percent of GDP and yet
they have given no money to raising
wages nothing to reinvesting it looks
like maybe they along with the
Republican Congress want to keep Aslaug
assured
enemy so that Blackie the median wage in
this country has fallen actually
actually big our show to you I know the
famous fake look I am all over
davis-bacon thank you I wanna be market
advocates pointed out that if you
threaten the economy with taxes and
regulations as has been done people will
not invest in the economy people are
investing outside the United States more
we ought to have a better atmosphere
here for investment and job creation and
then both the companies that have money
here and foreigners should be investing
in our country you're talking about
immigrants well come days you gotta read
up on they're not sending their money
either I am all over that alright
alright time thank you folks
great you coming Thank You panel real
time we Gilmore asked bill and its
guests your blessings right after the
show at hbo.com